We got the phone guys
I also got a few other red goodies too
This is not a part of that
And this isn't either
This is one of my favourite vlogging tripods, it's incredible
Not a part of this unboxing
So things we're going to be checking  out today;
We've got the red Apple Watch band,
We've got a white case because I kinda feel like this is gonna look a lot better than any other color cases on the red iPhone
Basically it's gonna cover up the red
I tweeted something the other day; if you buy a red iPhone and then you put a case on it will anyone even know that you actually have a red iPhone?
The new berry colored leather case
And just the basic red case that they've had for a while
And of course the star of the show, the new red iPhone
One of the things I'm already a big fan of is the silver logo
I dont even need scissors because they've got a nice little pull tab here for us
So I did get the 256, I'm not 100% sure if this is going to be the new phone that I keep because I really do absolutely love my jet black phone
The more that I look at it, the more that I am really, really into it!
I also got the unlocked version. Most of the phones that I have previously got were tied to a carrier and this is unlocked.
and when I travel abroad, the best thing ever is being able to get a T-mobile SIM card
and you'll be able to actually have data and not worry about any overages.
Let's lift her up
Look at this red
I mean this is super red
I am shocked, actually
At how red it is
I mean, this, this is...
This is RED.
Oh, I know what you're saying. Yeah no kidding Justine it's red.
To look at this, this close-up, and actually see the true color;
Super red!
I don't know what to do.
What do you guys think? Do you think I should keep this phone or stick with the jet black phone?
You guys have never taken a YouTube poll before.
I've actually never used it before but i'm going to put one right now on this video so an annotation will pop up and you guys will be able to decide if I should keep the phone or do i not keep the phone.
As with all iPhones they come with a USB charging brick, you've got your earpods and you've got your lightning cable
And of course the infamous dongle
First up the red iPhone case,
This is not the new one that just came out, this is the old version
I've actually really wanted a red case for quite a while
because I thought that it would incredible on the black phone
Which it does, I've seen other people with it and...
Hmm, it looks good!
And I love this color of red
This is definitely more of a berry
which I feel like this case will match a little bit better
This is the berry leather iPhone case
Here you guys can see the difference of the colors of red
I mean this is a much brighter red
This is more Nintendo Switch red
whereas this is, I don't know, I guess berry really is the only other kind of color I can think of
a more strawberry-ish color,
unless you have some strawberries that are full of GMO's
then this is defintely... what you're gonna be getting
I'm not sure if you're actually gonna be able to tell
that there is a difference, but again...
This is a much brighter color
This is a little bit more of a darker hue
If you don't want to buy an entirely new phone
here's what you do
you buy a case!
For the longest time I had a white case on my black phone
and I thought it looked really, really good.
So wah... Oh my goodness
This is gonna drive me crazy
like that looks awful, I don't like this look at all
It's essentially like a mistake, like that's...
That does not look good
Look at the front, cool.
WHAT'S THIS!
It's like I spilled a little tiny bit of my jello
or my cherry pudding or...
some nail polish on my phone
And this doesn't look like it should be a thing!
Let's open up the berry case
This could be the answer
Still the colors are off, and if you're somebody who pays a lot of attention to detail and small little design things drive you absolutely crazy
I don't know if there's a good answer for you
I'm not sure what to say...
So, this is the leather case and this is the silicone case
And you can definitely tell, hopefully, that this is much brighter than this one
Most of the people who saw that the red iphone was announced were basically saying, well why didnt they make it an all black front
I mean this looks really good
Red.. Black...
Red... White...
There's just something about having a completely flushed screen
All black that looks really, really good
And speaking of miss-matching, this black and red like that
I am unsure of what color combination that you guys would want to do with the red phone
Because none of these cases are aesthetically pleasing
Moving on to the red apple watch band, this is actually something that i have wanted to get for quite awhile
I have the white ceramic phone
A lot of you guys always wonder why i wear my apple watch on the wrong hand
And if you're left handed, this isn't the wrong hand
This is the right hand
And technically it is the right hand
Now this looks good
So what i was able to do this and rock this with no case on
Man
Yeah
This looks great
So, now I've got a few questions for you guys. Number one i already asked,  Do i keep the phone?
Do i switch from the jet black to the red, and which case combination did you guys like the best?
Did you like the black with the red? The white with the red? The red with the red? Or the leather berry with the red?
My favorite phone color combination, the black with the black definitely makes everything super seamless
I also like the white with the black, because when i do wear my apple watch with the ceramic it matches
I mean these are all stupid insignificant details that probably no one else in their right mind would know
But you... or me
And for the red iphone, lets just say this mophie case looks incredible
Look at this.. That actually matches almost perfectly
Okay, well now that i look at it through the camera, it's a little bit off
But still
You guys get the point
Thank you guys so much for watching, hope you guys enjoy the video, and as always i will see you guys in the next one
And make sure you guys answer those questions in the comments below, and i will see you later
Probably tomorrow
Oh and did i mention that i was first in line for the iphone, the red iphone. Because there was no one else there at 8am today
Because that's crazy why would somebody do that